haben maschinen ein bewusstsein schon
seitdem es die ersten automatisierten
maschinen gibt haben die menschen angst
davor dass sich diese gegen die
menschheit auflegen könnten roboter
androiden oder künstliche intelligenz
all das könnte sich eines tages gegen
uns verbünden und die menschheit
versklaven oder sogar ausrotten nur dass
die meisten maschinen nicht mal im
ansatz dazu in der lage wären klar zum
einen stecken viele an einer stelle fest
oder haben gar keine beweglichen teile
aber was fast allen maschinen der
heutigen zeit fehlt ist ein bewusstsein
um sich gegen die menschheit auflegen zu
können muss die maschine erst mal wissen
dass es menschen gibt dass sie eine
maschine ist und sie bräuchte freien
willen und ein tieferes verständnis von
sich und ihrer umgebung die allermeisten
roboter sind blind für ihre umgebung sie
wissen nicht dass sie existieren dass
die hände haben oder dass sie gerade ein
auto bauen oder was auch immer sie
gerade tun
sie tun es nur weil sich schaltkreise
haben die in einer bestimmten
reihenfolge angeordnet sind und
ingenieure und programmierer und ein
ganzer haufen intelligenter leute sich
vorher gedanken darüber gemacht haben
wie diese schaltkreise angeordnet werden
müssen
wer den film the world's end gesehen hat
ist ein sehr geiler film der weiß das
wort roboter bedeutet sklave und genau
das sind maschinen auch sklaven ihrer
macher und erschaffer also kein grund
zur panik
roboter werden sich nicht gegen ihre
schöpfer auflehnen oder doch vor kurzem
gab es einen durchbruch in der forschung
der anlass zur sorge sein könnte
in new york wurde im juli 2015 mit drei
robotern ein gedanken experiment
durchgeführt
zwei von den drei robotern erhielten
eine pille die sich sturm machte für die
roboter ist das ein knopfdruck der die
lautsprecher stumm stellte der dritte
roboter allerdings erhielt ein placebo
nun fragte der leiter des experiments
welche pille habt ihr bekommen
und was macht der roboter
alle drei roboter versuchten und not zu
sagen weil sie keine möglichkeit hatten
herauszufinden welche pille sie bekommen
haben aber nur der eine roboter konnte
sprechen nachdem er seine eigene stimme
hörte realisierte er dass er der einzige
ist der die placebo pillen bekommen hat
und noch sprechen kann und korrigierte
seine antwort sofort das erfordert von
ihm dass er zuhört und versteht dass er
gerade seine eigene stimme gehört hat
und auch versteht dass ihr jemand
anderes ist als die anderen zwei roboter
also dass ihr ein eigenständiges
individuum ist auf uns menschen wird
diese aufgabe ziemlich trivial und
extrem einfach aber ein eigenes
bewusstsein zu haben ist nicht
selbstverständlich
mit hilfe des spiegel tests wird
versucht zu erkennen ob ein lebewesen
sich im spiegel erkennt und versteht
dass es sich selber sieht bestanden wird
er nur von verschiedenen affenarten und
manchmal auch von vögeln hunde und
katzen fallen meistens durch menschen
reagieren auf spiegel ab einem alter von
zirka anderthalb jahren und ab zwei
jahren bestehen menschen durchweg den
spiegel test indem sie eine markierung
im spiegel erkennen und diese dann am
eigenen körper suchen
und dieser spiegelt es wurde vor einiger
zeit vom roboter kombico bestanden
diese arten von tests beweisen dass
diese maschinen ein gewisses
selbstverständnis haben sie verstehen
dass sie existieren
anders als zum beispiel ein boom bei
wenn ein humba gegen eine wand fährt
löst das einen sensor aus durch eine
reihe von statements bleibt der rumba
stehen dreht sich um und fährt dann
weiter
er weiß aber gar nicht dass er gerade
gegen eine wand gefahren ist oder was
eine wand überhaupt ist er weiß nicht
mal dass er überhaupt fährt denn das ist
für ihn nur eine weitere ausgabe wenn
das dann das stellt euch vor ihr wert in
einem abgeschlossenen raum
nach kurzer zeit schiebt euch
irgendjemand zettel unter der tür durch
nur mit dem problem dass die zettel in
einer sprache geschrieben sind wir
überhaupt nicht versteht
ihr habt allerdings ein buch das euch
genau sagt was ihr auf welches zeichen
antworten müsst wenn wir das geschrieben
wird dann schreibe ich das hier und bei
dem hier mal ich mal so was hier gemeint
also lustig drauflos und von außen
betrachtet könnte man denken ihr
unterhaltet euch mit der anderen
personen in dieser fremden sprache aber
eigentlich befolgt er nur befehle oder
ihr versteht nicht was ihr da tut und
genauso ist der rumba auch er befolgt
nur befehle
ja nicht versteht aber woher wissen wir
dann dass der kleine roboter von vorhin
nicht auch nur mit einer reihe von
statements programmiert wurde
nachdem das experiment vorbei war hat
der roboter seine erkenntnisse in einem
blogeintrag aufgeschrieben
hiermit kann man nachvollziehen wie der
roboter zu seinem schluss gekommen ist
das alles kann man in der
wissenschaftlichen studie vom experiment
nachlesen link dazu und ein video das
experiment hat also gezeigt dass
maschinen zu mehr in der lage sind als
wir ursprünglich gedacht haben und dass
man sich vorsehen muss wenn es um das
thema künstliche intelligenz geht
natürlich gehört zu bewusstsein und
selbstverständnis viel mehr als das was
der roboter hier vorhin gezeigt hat und
je nach blickwinkel könnte man sogar
argumentieren dass das wirklich gar kein
richtiges bewusstsein war
wie viel von seiner antwort stand jetzt
wirklich von ihm selber wie viel von den
programmierern dass er sich zum beispiel
erst entschuldigt ist zwar süß kommt
aber bestimmt nicht aus
schuldbewusstsein
aber das wirft auch wieder fragen auf
inwiefern haben wir freien willen ist
nicht jede aktion die wir machen eine
chemikalie reaktion in unserem gehirn
ist nicht sowieso alles vorprogrammiert
was wir machen
was haltet ihr von dem thema schreibt
mir eure gedanken unten in die
kommentare ich bin sehr gern leicht
darüber diskutieren und das war die
erste folge doktor watson
wenn es euch gefallen hat dann abonniert
doch diesen kanal und es würde mich sehr
interessieren was sie hier von haltet
also schreibt ihr eure meinung in die
kommentare was kann ich besser machen
was gefällt euch gut und welche themen
wollt ihr vielleicht in zukunft hier auf
dem kanal sehen das war es soweit
nächste woche kommt das nächste video
und bis dahin